Feminism is 1 cancer
If I could I would remove him from schools
and I would put 1 sewing subject
because it empowers more to be 1 button
No,
there is no need to laugh at this,
gentlemen.
No laughing matter
We do not hate women
In our party there are many women of great value.
almost as much as that of men
If women are paid less
is because that is what they decide
and if there are positions with more men
is because men are genetically more adapted
These statements,
gentlemen
look like something out of a manual
of the women's section of Franco's phalanx
but they are public statements
carried out by Vox leaders
In recent months
Leaders that it should not be forgotten
They have acceded to regional and local positions
of governmental responsibilities
Thanks to the favorable joy of the popular party